- Michael Ealy, I've been seeing you.
I can feel that you're
dying to say something.
You've just been moving
so much on this screen.
Have you ever heard anything like this?
- Yeah, you know, this is an
incredible, incredible story.
Mike, that kind of hate that you describe
that you feel when people look
at you because they see the tattoos
and everything, just for the record,
this is what a lot of Black
people feel every day.
And so that I understand
what you're talking about.
Two, Tiffany, I think
you are living proof.
You're kind of an angel,
to be honest with you.
- Thank you.
- And you're living proof
that if you can lead
with humanity, respect and love,
then the barrier of hate can
be broken, but it takes two.
I think that's the key that
I'm taking away from this,
is that both of you have some sort of
mutual respect for the other.
And that foundation has
led to this friendship.
Kelly, this is a story.
You know how you do your
year wrap-up episode with great stories?
I don't know how you beat this one.